i watched like your introduction video
on the youtube channel
i'm like wow this chick is very aussie
yeah
like holy [ __ ] so did you do a video
where you
did a test to see how aussie you were oh
yeah i did
i watched that one with the slang yeah
yeah because i'm not really fond of like
australian slang
i don't know it's terrible arvo it's
nonsense
that's what do you mean that's like
that's not slang that's actually like do
you want a copper or like i can't say
that
i've never used bottle o before because
like you're you're that's a liquor store
you're just adding you're just adding a
syllable to a word that doesn't need a
symbol added to it yeah i don't know
yeah
but like bottle oh i feel was like who
the [ __ ] came up with that it's a word
let me end a word that ends in a verb
you just thought it was a bottle this
whole time i thought it was just a
bottle this whole time joey says i'm
just like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about
not long enough apparently what the [ __ ]
yeah if you say like i'm just popping
okay
okay i probably for even name speakers
we get [ __ ] confused as well
it's like oh i'm just gonna pop over to
the bottle it means like i'm gonna go
buy some alcohol at the liquor store
liquor stores
sorry americans we we've hurt youtube
yeah sorry yeah we've
maybe we've been too harsh on you